ring the japanese-version the movie that
started a gigantic explosion of what
eventually became known as j-horror
yeah all those horror films you've seen
come out since 1998 that featured a
woman with long hair crawling around on
the ground and a weird strange deformed
way
yeah they copied off this movie this
film started a huge trend and still to
this day is the highest-grossing
Japanese horror film of all time and of
course it got an American remake which
I'm also going to be reviewing because
the newest rings film the third in the
American franchise is coming out this
October so I thought it would be fun to
talk about a select few of the movies
that are in this franchise because
there's actually a lot of other ones
that were released in Japan various
spin-offs of sorts I'm not going to talk
about all of them but I'm definitely
gonna review this one the American
remake and the American Ring to look
forward to that let's start talking
about Ring this movie scared the
out of me I'm serious this movie is so
absolutely unnerving there's a very
low-budget sense to this film that
really works in its favor it's also
edited and directed very tensely it's a
very quiet film sound design is
extremely important in this movie jump
scares are kept at a wonderful minimum
there's barely any actually there's a
lot of sequences where you would expect
a loud burst of music like moments where
the main heroine see someone reflected
in her television screen but you don't
get that burst of music you just see it
and it's very unsettling and that
feeling of creepiness infects this
entire film as I watched it I began to
grow warm inside but it wasn't like
happy sunshine rainbows warm Morgan
Freeman being my grandpa and reading me
a bedtime story warm no not like that
it was weird I can't actually explain it
and that's one of the biggest things
about this movie that I think is so
effective it leaves you feeling off it
just makes you feel changed and this
film really did that to me if you guys
have seen the American remake I'm not
going to talk about comparisons in this
video because this movie came before it
I'm going to act like the American
remake doesn't even exist when I review
this movie but if you've seen it you
know the plot a cursed videotape is
being spread amongst people when you
watch this tape you supposedly die in
seven days and our main
characters a woman and a man who are at
one point in time married who do have a
son together watch this tape together
and embark on a mystery to discover why
this tape is killing people and what is
really behind the images shown in this
video it's very well paced if you
appreciate slow burning horror if you
like a movie that takes its time to set
up its characters to set up the scares
if you like a horror film that really
sneaks underneath your skin and
surprises you in various ways then this
movie is definitely going to give you
the goosebumps because my god it really
did for me and I am not usually rattled
by horror films because I've seen so
many of them a lot of people talk about
oh I was afraid to look in my closet at
night or I had to turn off my lights on
that doesn't usually happen to me but
last night when I watched this movie it
was at night I was alone in the house my
wife was out doing something else and I
just had this sudden feeling oh my god
I'm alone in this house this movie made
me realize that rarely do I ever feel
that from a horror film there's a tragic
sense to the story that unfolds that
makes it feel more impactful than just
some scary thing someone watches on a
tape the Maine couple and their past is
always something that's very central to
their characters and the film has a
really good sense of tragedy and that's
really what makes this movie work beyond
just the scare element there's a very
sad feeling to things that you uncover
in this film as for issues with this
film something that did bother me is
that the husband character often is the
exposition mouthpiece various scenes are
just him sitting down explaining this
woman's past as they uncover it and I
wish that there was a more interesting
way for them to have conveyed that to us
as audience members beyond him just
sitting there constantly explaining this
backstory to us because it makes the
main character a little less interesting
because she doesn't figure out that much
on her own she kind of just exists to be
the audience character that is
experiencing all these weird things for
the first time and she reacts to it in a
way that we can understand so I suppose
my biggest issue with this movie along
with that unnecessary constant
exposition is that the main character
just isn't as interesting as she could
have been beyond that this movie
unsettled me it is creepy it definitely
got under my skin it is a very good
low-budget Japanese horror film I highly
recommend checking out ring and I'm
going to give
and a so guys like I said I want to
review a select few of the ring films
leading up to the newest rings coming
out later in October you guys are the
best look forward to more those thank
you so much as always for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get steppen eyes
[Applause]
[Music]